[Musique]
donc je suis jean élève responsable du
service infrastructure donc des gares
routières dans toute l'île on s'occupe
aussi des arrêts sur toute l'île donc
tout le réseau car jaune
[Applaudissements]
donc je m'occupe d'une vingtaine de
personnes donc en trois équipes
principal sur le réseau et
nous aussi d'emballer gars routier où on
nous avons des agents en poste je
prépare aussi la paix attendu que je
transmets aux 6-10 comptabilité je
travaille de concert avec le conseil
général pour les aider techniquement
dans des projets dans des améliorations
niveau confort dans les gares routières
et sur les avait même et en général tout
tout ce qui amène à améliorer le
transport des usagers
[Musique]
ici en fait dont ils font les préventive
ils le font le mardi et le vendredi donc
une liste bien défini
moi ma présence c'est parce qu'on m'a
signalé qu' à des signalements sur le
banc qui est serait à redresser et
éventuellement un petit d'élagage
il n'y a pas de
ce qui me plaît dans mon travail c'est
la liberté donc d'agir
par comme je l'entends mais comme il le
coup et c'est la
multiplicité des tâches ne tenait donc
c'est jamais pratiquement la même chose
à part les tâches administratives
il ya toujours des nouveautés surtout
que là je conseil général a décidé de
promouvoir de créer des arts est typique
bad boy alliés des quais pmr la
nouveauté n'arrête pas et ça me tue
la qualité premier je dirais aimé mais
déjà ce qu'on fait et aussi
être ouvert aux discussions on reste pas
mal de problèmes sociaux donc il faut
être là quand le quand le personnel en a
besoin
[Musique]
non j'ai passé mon permis de conduire de
transport en commun en métropole arrivé
sur l'île j'ai trouvé tout de suite une
fonction donc de conducteurs dans une
entreprise privée je travaille cinq ans
après quand j'ai su que la première le
premier réseau de transport urbain
allaient se créer dans le sud est lors
l'ouest donc sous l'égide du sivom je me
suis inscrit j'ai je me suis athée comme
conducteur je suis passé contrôleurs
trois mois après on m'a désigné cheikh
contrôleurs et de fil en aiguille j'ai
geste de michel mouvement après j'ai été
par les cars jaunes ou voilà donc je me
suis fais moi même et j'ai vu ce qui me
plaisait vraiment là dedans c'était
c'était tout ce qui allait vers l'avenir
[Musique]
pour me déstresser du boulot entre
autres de la vie récentes des routes ma
passion principale c'est le parapente je
patine depuis une vingtaine d'années
j'ai je fais brûler des gens je me
déciderai de cette façon surtout dans le
dans les montagnes du sud dans les
rivières ou jamais car si on peut dire